so with the Avengers age of Ultron
coming out in 2015 it seemed like it was
a highly important thing to do a video
about Ultron because I think there are
people who know who Ultron is they know
who all Tron is most commonly a foe of
but I think the people are to some
degree a little unsure about not only
the backstory of Ultron but as some
degrees the very basis for Ultron's
existence and why it is that he comes
into conflict with the Avengers
so Ultron first appears to us an issue
number 54 of the Avengers and as we
progress through this storyline at the
beginning of this video I would like you
all to pay particular attention to a
couple things the first thing is the
group the Masters of evil and the second
thing is the mannerisms and the way in
which Ultron talks and the reason why is
because this will become particularly
important both with regards to the
backstory of Ultron and the basis behind
his consistent opposition to the group
of the Avengers so as the comic starts
off we see that Hank Pym is upgrading
the security system of Avengers mansion
any summons Jarvis who is the personal
butler of Tony Stark who is serving at
the Avengers mansion to ensure that none
of the booby traps that have been setup
will be unwittingly activated by Jarvis
and will only be activated by
individuals who are not supposed to be
there we also see Jarvis acting a little
strange that is to say that he's acting
in such a way that his loyalties come
into question we also see Jarvis leave
the Avengers mansion under the guise of
taking an afternoon for himself and
in a hideout with the Masters of evil
who are being led by an individual named
the Crimson cowl now at this point we
don't know who the Crimson cowl is we
don't know what he looks like or
anything of that sort he's kind of
covered in a Crimson cowl and he is kind
of shrouded in mystery but it is
established that he is the mastermind
behind whatever planet is that has been
set up and we learned that the plan
involves Jarvis handing over the
security blueprints to the Crimson cowl
so that the Masters of evil can invade
the Avengers mansion without triggering
any of the traps that had been set up by
Hank Pym eventually the Masters of evil
managed to break into the Avengers
mansion and they managed to also kidnap
the wasp along with the rest of the
Avengers and place them sell them in a
sort of suspended animation or in a
prison of sorts now at this time the
Masters of evil really kind of call out
the Crimson cowl and demand that he
present himself that they that he show
them who he is and what we see is a
reveal that Jarvis himself is the
Crimson cowl but we also see that the
orders that were being given to the
Masters of evil were being given to them
by a robot now this is very interesting
because at first it really kind of
appears that Jarvis is masterminding the
whole thing and that the robot is simply
carrying out the instructions that he
has given to the Masters of evil in part
two of this comic and issue number 55 we
see that the Masters of evil are taking
the bodies of the Avengers to a location
and kind of a derelict hidden part
that's a hidden basis underground we
also see that the Crimson cowl despite
having revealed himself as Jarvis still
maintains his guise and again he doesn't
show his face or any other part of his
body at this point one of the members of
the Masters of evil I believe it's Klaw
kind of challenges the authority of the
Crimson cowl and the Crimson cowl really
kind of takes the full brunt of the
powers that the Klaw offers and
establishes himself as being far more
powerful than anything that the clock
could present towards him and it's
really kind of at a point where he's
getting ready to kill the claw and the
claw states that he of course made him
that he really recognizes his place in a
bigger picture now and agrees to being
subservient to the Crimson cowl at this
point the Crimson cowl reveals his plan
and his plan is to place the Avengers in
a hydrogen bomb and to blackmail New
York now what his purpose is behind
blackmailing New York is something that
I do not remember off the top of my head
but suffice it to say as always the
avengers come out on top now what we
learn over the course of the remainder
of this comic are a couple things one we
learned that Ultron himself the robot is
in fact the actual leader he is crimson
cow and that Jarvis has been placed in a
state of hypnosis so to speak and that
Jarvis wasn't really realizing what it
was that he was doing but once he comes
to once he learns what it was that he's
done he manages to escape not
necessarily in the sense that he breaks
out but in the sense that he has left to
being destroyed by Ultron but is
ultimately able to make his way back to
the Avengers mansion at this point he
comes into contact with one of the
members of the Masters of evil an
individual named Black Knight and Black
Knight reveals that his entire goal with
regards to joining the Masters of evil
was to circumvent their plan and keep it
from coming to fruition he along with
Jarvis are able to free the Avengers and
the Avengers supposedly defeat Ultron
now
Ultron really is a destroyed per se in
this instance but he simply states that
it's really kind of his mission now his
personal goal to destroy the Avengers
Ultron reappears on issues number 57 and
58 of the Avengers and in issue number
not only does ultron return but were
also introduced to a new villain called
the vision and the vision is an Android
that was created by Ultron for the
purpose of destroying the Avengers but
almost immediately after the vision
comes into conflict with the Avengers he
begins to rebel against his programming
and by the end of the comic he is a
member of the Avengers and with the
assistance of the Avengers he is able to
defeat Ultron in issue number 58 this is
when we actually get the backstory of
both the vision and Ultron now we're not
going to go into the backstory of the
vision will actually do a video about
him separately but in the backstory of
Ultron
we learn is that Ultron is a result of
creation at the hands of Hank Pym and
Hank Pym had been kind of delving into
the idea of artificial intelligence and
Ultron was the first step along that
process we see that Ultron activates
himself in a very primitive state to the
surprise of a Hank Pym and over the
course of a minute or two Ultron grows
from being a baby referring to Hank Pym
as daddy to an adult referring to Hank
Pym as father and this is when the most
interesting part of Ultron begins to
manifest itself and this is the Oedipus
complex that Ultron suffers from now the
Oedipus complex is a phrase that was
coined by Sigmund Freud and his
psychoanalytical concepts but the idea
of the Oedipus complex actually
originates with a Greek mythological
character named Oedipus who killed his
father and married his mother now this
is actually the idea that the play
Hamlet is based off of however we see
that Ultron overpowers Hank Pym and he
wipes the memories of Ultron from Hank
Tim's mine and also implants a desire in
Hank Pym to never return to his
laboratory so once he is discovered once
Hank Pym is discovered by his wife Jan
Van Dyne is assumed that the destruction
that has taken place is the result of
some sort of experiment that has gone
awry and Hank Pym because he knows
nothing about Ultron doesn't really know
anything enough to refute this and so he
and Jan Van Dyne leave and they take up
residence at the Avengers mansion now
from this point until the chronological
appearance of Ultron in the Avengers
issue number 54 we don't really know
what he does but what we can say or at
the very least we can assume is that
this very primitive version of Ultron
can be referred to as Ultron 1 now
Ultron's two three and four we don't
really know what they look like and we
have no idea what shape they took on
it's entirely possible that Ultron's two
three and four looked almost exactly
like Ultron 1 and it wasn't until Ultron
5 appeared and the Avengers issue number
5 about 54 that he actually has a
humanoid appearance but what we can say
is that the overriding factor in
Ultron's
aggression and his desire for
self-improvement by virtue of improving
his ability to interface with technology
and taking on additional powers is based
under the overriding goal to destroy
Hank Pym as irrational as this may be
and this is one of the more interesting
concepts when it comes to Ultron because
what we see over the course of the next
several decades and Marvel Comics is
that Ultron will be re recreated by
someone it may be that in the Avengers
issues number 66 67 and 68
he's recreated by the vision and this is
when he gets his adamantium body we see
that he creates individual such as
Jocasta who is designed to be a Android
mate for Ultron but Jocasta turns
against and turns against Ultron when
it's revealed that in order for Jocasta
to have sentience in order for her to
exist the mind of the wasp who is the
wife of Hank Pym must be implanted in
Jocasta which will cost the life of the
wasp of course Jocasta warns the
Avengers of what's going on and Jocasta
is left lifeless however the wasp is
left alive and she's unharmed in New
York deal we see this take place time
and time again with Ultron he is
destroyed he's reconstituted whether by
his own means or by some external factor
individual and each time he comes back
he is given a higher number so we see
that each time he returns he takes on an
extra number and as a result he becomes
more and more dangerous with each return
that he makes to Marvel Comics to come
into conflict with the Avengers so a
popular misconception about the villain
Ultron is that he is a Marvel version of
the villain doomsday from DC Comics and
what I mean by that is in DC Comics
neumes Day is of course most notable as
being the villain that killed Superman
but where doomsday will die and then
return and be impervious to whatever it
was that killed him Ultron will die and
be rebuilt but he will not be rebuilt
and be impervious to whatever it was
that had previously destroyed him
there will be an augment to his powers
and there may be an adjustment and an
expansion of an existing power but it
doesn't mean that he can't be killed the
same way again
for example there was an instance where
the Scarlet Witch had destroyed him by
short-circuiting there was an instance
where Wonder Man had thrown him against
a wall and caused his internal
mechanical systems to become disrupted
and to destroy him there was an instance
where Johnny Storm had used his nova
blast to destroy Ultron so it doesn't
necessarily mean that Ultron isn't
vulnerable when he dies to whatever it
was it killed him when he returns it
simply just means that he will augment
his powers and give him more abilities
that he previously had thereby giving
him more of an edge over the Avengers
when they can bat each other and this is
what's really kind of interesting about
Ultron for the most part when you look
at a lot of characters and even super
villains in the Marvel Comics they're
really kind of established with one set
of powers now those powers may expand in
terms of their capabilities but in the
end it's still the same based power for
example with Cyclops in the beginning we
see Cyclops with the ability to use as
optic blast as a concussive force he's
able to knock people out or he's able to
destroy walls but as time progresses in
the Marvel Comics we see him able to use
his optic blast to slice mountains in
half with Ultron when he comes back his
powers expand and he gains more
abilities so we're in the beginning of
in the beginning of his first appearance
in the Avengers issue number 54 he first
appears and he has enhanced strength and
enhanced speed and he has the ability to
hypnotize people and plant subliminal
messages that can be activated later on
but by the time it comes to an end by
the time his character as far as we know
dies in the age of Ultron he has
involtini has radar senses and he can
create force fields that he can fly and
he can disrupt electromagnetic spectrum
x' and he has you know heat vision and
all different kinds of things that he
can do size alteration and all sorts of
stuff and so he's kind of a constantly
evolving character he's kind of a
constantly evolving villain and every
time he returns whether it's because the
vision reconstituted him whether it's
because he had taken over the mind of
Hank Pym who in turn created another
version of Ultron in a female form or
whether it's because he had taken over
the mine by hypnotizing Iron Man and
forced him into being rebuilt
he constantly comes back as being a more
powerful version of his former self so
the legacy created by Ultron is actually
pretty significant and the reason why I
say that is because Ultron was really
kind of the precursor to the Days of
Future past now this doesn't necessarily
mean that they are directly related it
doesn't necessarily mean that the events
that took place in the Avengers issues
number 54 and 55 led to the creation of
the storyline of the x-men Days of
Future past it's really more of a
spiritual predecessor and what I mean by
that is the Days of Future past was a
revolutionary kind of comic in the world
of Marvel Comics it allowed Marvel to
turn the bend and go from a
family-friendly kind of comic to a more
serious and adult oriented comic but
Ultron was the precursor to that Ultron
and villains like him involved in the
kind of storylines that they were
involved in laid the foundation so that
story lines like the Days of Future past
in the House of M and onslaught and
decimation those could all be built upon
that foundation and this is the reason
why I suggested taking a look at the
group the Masters of evil the reason why
I wanted you to keep this in the back of
your heads is because the Masters of
evil represent an antiquated group of
villains and Marvel Comics the Masters
of evil were at their prime before most
villains of one or more of the Avengers
at the time however these were Avengers
who are villains who appeared and the
storylines of the comics of journey into
mystery and tales of suspense but they
were old guard these were comic villains
that were being phased out and that is
the reason why for the most part despite
the fact that they were premiere
villains at one point and the Avengers
issues number 54 and 55 they're really
kind of relegated to the position of
being henchmen that's really all they
are they're really nothing more than
that and so when you look at this kind
of concept what you see is that this old
guard of characters are being shunted
aside and they're being pushed out of
the way to make way for more realistic
more gritty and darker villains in the
world of Marvel Comics as a whole
and this to me is the most significant
part of Ultron not his abilities not his
his position as the most enduring foe of
the Avengers but because he along with
others like him allowed Marvel to
introduce the concept to Marvel Comics
of a very darker kind of person of a
very dark and gritty kind of instance
whereby we could have characters that
would do whatever it took to achieve
their ends because when you think about
this in issues number 54 and 55 Ultron
was willing to detonate a hydrogen bomb
in the city of New York in order to
destroy both the Avengers and to bring
New York to its knees a hydrogen bomb to
this date as far as I know is the most
destructive weapon imaginable and this
is really kind of interesting because
when you look at the Masters of evil
these were villains who despite how
laughable the cause may have been
endeavored to do things like take over
the world these guys fell in line with a
villains whose goal was to rob banks and
to amass a lot of money they were
reminiscent of a time in which villains
were more childlike than they were more
adult-like and so when you compare these
two things together you really become
more understanding of the idea that
Marvel didn't really want to stay with
this concept of childlike villains and
even some of the names of the Masters of
evil radioactive man the Klaw
these were silly names if any villain
like that were to pop up in this day and
age in Marvel Comics a name like the
claw or a name like the radioactive man
he would be considered laughable and no
one would really take him seriously
because he is reminiscent of an
antiquated time in Marvel Comics that we
simply just don't adhere to anymore
because the idea of a villain whose goal
is to amass wealth isn't something that
we take seriously because in Marvel
Comics now you see scenarios whereby
individuals don't want to rob banks they
want to rule the world they want to rule
the universe they want to take over
entire galaxies or they simply just want
to eradicate all life any way possible
and in any possible way that they can
so as far as I know the plot lines the
basis for the Avengers age of Ultron is
being kept very hush-hush and the reason
why is because I don't think Marvel just
really wants to give anything away after
these success both financial and
critical success of the Avengers Marvel
is really wanting to capitalize on this
and I feel like going about using Ultron
as a villain is a great way to do it but
as Joss Whedon has stated there really
is not going to be any crossover between
the age of Ultron storyline and the age
of Ultron film they're simply using the
name and so this begs the question how
much backstory if any are we actually
going to get about Ultron we really
haven't been introduced to Hank Pym yet
and Hank Pym will be introduced after
the Avengers age of Ultron so I think we
can kind of assume that at this point
Ultron is going to be the creation of
somebody else but again and the Avengers
issues number 54 and 55 Ultron just
shows up and he fights the Avengers and
the Avengers manage to somewhat succeed
but Ultron stays alive and it eventually
comes back time and time again to
confront them later on in the comics
it's not until much later that we learn
a couple things we learn that Ultron was
designed by Hank Pym we learn in the age
of Ultron storyline that Hank Pym
designed Ultron in order to have the
mental faculties and the concept of
human beings so that he could be more
human and so I'm not really sure if this
is the direction that Marvel's going to
go
I'd be very intrigued and I would love
to see a film where by Marvel introduces
Ultron and Ultron fights The Avengers
and Ultron is seemingly defeated but we
learn in some future film after ant-man
that it was in fact Hank Pym that
created Ultron we don't really know how
these things are going to go most likely
it will be that the iron that Iron Man
Tony Stark created Ultron that will that
seems to be the most logical scenario
and the reason why simply because Tony
Stark is the foremost authority on
technology in terms of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe at the moment now
when it comes to technological
intelligence Hank
him as far beyond anything that Tony
Stark is capable of but again we haven't
seen hank pym yet and so it really kind
of begs the question what's Marvel going
to do what direction are they going to
take and I like the idea that this
really speculation at this point I'd
like the idea that there really isn't
anything known in terms of what the
plots going to be despite the fact that
Marvel has already started filming the
movie so for me this is a very exciting
thing because Ultron to this day remains
a huge fan favorite among Marvel comic
fans because he is for the most part the
most enduring foe of the Avengers his
goal is to simply eradicate life that's
it that's all he wants to do he wants to
destroy Hank Pym and he wants to destroy
humanity and that's it there's no
complication there's no desire to rule
the world there's no desire to force
humanity to be subjected to him there's
no desire to run a country or anything
like that there's no politics none of
that stuff he simply just wants to
destroy people and so I'm very very
interested to see exactly how it is that
this is going to play out in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but regardless of
what road they choose to take regardless
of how they choose to implement the
storyline I highly doubt that this film
is going to be anything short of
absolutely fantastic with that being
said I'm going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and
don't forget to post your request for
Marvel requests Monday in the comment
section I will catch you guys later
peace